The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's get ready.
If good, you should
receive some handouts.
So the TAs are walking around,
so you should slowly get those.
This is the second
lecture on number theory,
and we're going to cover
for a lot of stuff.
And actually, we're
going to start
with encryption, which is an
application of number theory.
And we'll take that as a theme
throughout the whole lecture.
And so, in this way, you can
see how useful number theory is.
Now, encryption--
yeah, what is it?
So let's first talk
about it a little bit.
Maybe some of you
have heard about it.
Cryptology in general is the
art of hiding information.
And encryption is
a very useful tool.
I'll only give a very
high level overview.
I mean, if you really want
to know more about this,
you should do a class in
crypto, or practical security.
So what's encryption?
The idea is usually
that, beforehand, we're
going to share a
whole bunch of keys.
So keys are exchanged between
a receiver and a sender.
And the whole idea is that
if I want to transmit, like,
a message to one
of you, well, there
could be someone
in the middle who
wants to intercept
my message, and wants
to find out what I'm saying.
So I do not like this.
And in order to avoid it,
I will use encryption,
which is some kind of algorithm
that actually transforms
my message m-- my plain
message-- by using
some kind of algorithm, E.
Some encryption algorithm--
it can be a function as
well-- that uses the keys
in order to transform this
into an encryption, which
we call m prime here.
So the plain text is, in the
clear, all the information
that I want to convey to
one of you, for example.
And m prime is somehow
a complete-- well,
a mixture of bits,
out of which I'm not
able to distill any information
about the plain text.
So encryption to a very
special kind of thing.
We're not going to talk about
the precise definitions here,
but we just take the
ID into this lecture.
Now, decryption is transforming
the cypher text back
into the plain text.
So we will start with
the encryption, m prime,
and we have some kind
of decryption algorithm.
And again, we can make use
of the keys we exchanged.
And we transform it back
into the plain message.
So only if I know the
keys, I can actually
transform back the encrypted
version into the plain version.
So in encryption schemes we
like both these algorithms
to be is really efficient.
And the security of such a
scheme-- well, the first kind
of intuition that
we can get is well,
if I'm a man in the
middle somewhere,
intercepting an encrypted
message-- m prime--
I should not be able to
get any information about m
if I have no knowledge
about those keys.
So this is the
example that we're
going to take throughout
this whole lecture.
So let's start with a
first possible scheme.
Turing, who lived around
1936-- he was 24 years old--
and he lived to
about-- actually,
I think he was about
54 when he died.
In any case, Turing was the one
who first originally proposed
to use number theory
in cryptography.
And before he joined the British
army, before the Second World
War, he actually
proposed a scheme,
but it got never published.
So here in this
class, we are going
to try to think about what
he could have thought about.
So we will have a
first scheme, which
we will call Turing's
code, version number one.
And the whole idea
is that we're going
to translate a message first
of all into a prime number,
because we want to use numbers.
We're here in
number theory class,
so we want to use some
tricks with numbers in order
to encrypt it.
So let's do this.
So for example, let's
take the word victory.
We can map this into an integer.
For example, we could
say, well, m is 22,
where I map V to--
because I know
V is the 22nd letter in the
alphabet, I just start with 22.
I is the ninth letter in the
alphabet, so I append 09.
C is the third letter in the
alphabet, I append 3-- 03.
I continue like this
and in end, over here
I've mapped Y to
the 25th letter.
Because it's the 25th letter
of alphabet, I write 25.
It turns out, I can just
add a couple of digits
more, if I specially
compute those.
In this case, I could
add 13, and then it
changes into a prime number.
Now we are not going to
talk about why this is,
and how this can
be done, and so on.
But it turns out that the
prime numbers are densely
distributed over the integers,
and it's really possible to,
just with a few extra
digits-- by selecting them
in a smart way-- to actually
create a prime number.
And also verify that it is a
prime number very efficiently.
So it's very easy to compute--
to translate such a word
into a prime number.
So this is how it all starts.
And just like in an
encryption scheme,
beforehand we are going
to exchange a key.
So we exchange the secret
prime in this example,
which we call k.
And the encryption
is very simple.
We are just going to
multiply m with k.
Now, you may wonder why this
is such a fantastic idea.
But let's just bear with me.
So m is this first prime
number, and we multiply it
by a second prime
number, and that's
going to be our encryption.
Now how do we decrypt?
That seems to be pretty
straightforward, right?
How do we do it?
We start off with m prime.
I know we have exchanged
this secret prime k,
so if I receive from
you this message--
this encrypted message--
well, I know the key, k.
So I just divide it by k.
Well, which is m k
divided k, and I get m.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
Now, as it turns out actually--
and I'll write it up here,
because we need it later-- that
it's not so trivial to actually
just give an m prime to
figure out what m is, or k.
m prime is a product of two
very large prime numbers,
and that turns out to be
a really hard problem.
Up to now, nobody
has really been
able to get a really efficient
algorithm to solve that.
So we may think this is secure.
So let me write it down
It's hard to factor
a product of two large primes.
You will actually
need this also,
when we come to the final
encryption scheme-- RSA
that we will discuss,
which is widely used.
But something is
wrong here, though.
This seems to be
too simple, right?
So what can we do if
we have like, say,
suppose I intercept
two encrypted messages.
What can I do?
So suppose I have
a first message, m
prime 1, which is the product
of a first plain message
times the key, k.
And I have a second
message that is
encrypted by using the same
key, which is m 2 times k.
Does anybody have an idea
what I could do here?
AUDIENCE: Find the GCD and
that would give you the key.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
could find the GCD
of m 1 prime and m 2 prime.
I've intercepted those two.
Now, m 1 is a prime number.
k is prime number, and
2 is a prime number.
k is a prime number
here, also, right?
So they're all relatively
prime towards one another.
The GCD of these two-- well, the
greatest common divisor is k.
So just by calculating the GCD
of the two encrypted messages,
I'll be able to figure
out what k is-- the key.
Well, if I know
the key, then I can
do the decryption
of any cypher text,
any encryption of a message
that I can intercept.
So this is not secure.
So how can we change this?
Can we create a different
kind of encryption scheme?
Let's do something
much more difficult,
and then we will get into
modular arithmetic and things
like that.
So let's do this.
So Turing's code,
version number two--
we try to do something much
more complicated than just
multiplying by prime.
So let's do the following.
So beforehand, we're
going to exchange not only
a secret prime k, but we will
also exchange a public prime.
So we exchange-- by public
we mean that anybody
can see this prime.
It's common knowledge.
A public prime p, and
also a secret prime k.
Let's see whether
this would work.
We have encryption.
Well, we're going to start
out exactly the same way.
First of all, I should tell you
how a message is represented.
The message is going to be
represented as a number, m,
in the range from 0, 1,
all the way to p minus 1.
And we will compute the
encryption as follows.
m is going to be the
remainder of m times k,
after dividing out as many
multiples of p as possible.
So notice we do kind
of the same thing.
We just multiply
by k, but now we
just take the remainder
after taking out
as many multiples of p.
Well, let's see whether
we can do the decryption.
It seems to be, like, a
next level of complexity.
So maybe that'll
help us here, right?
So how will we do decryption?
Well, somehow we would
like to divide by k.
But we cannot really
do that, right?
This does not make any sense.
So the decryption-- we
have no idea at this point
how to do this.
And now we can get into
modular arithmetic,
because it turns out that
we can sort of divide by k.
There exists what we call
multiplicative inverse
of k modulo p.
And I will explain all
those terminologies to you.
And then we will be
able to take m prime,
and transform it back to m.
So we will be able to get a
lot of this machinery going.
So let's find out
how this works.
So first of all, last time we
saw that we defined a and b
to be relatively prime.
So let me repeat that.
So a and b are relatively
prime if and only
if-- that's how we define
it-- if the GCD of a and b
is equal to 1.
And in last lecture
and in the recitation,
you got a different
proof, I think.
And we proved that,
actually, the GCD of a and b
is equal to the smallest
positive linear combination
of a and b.
So that means that
one, in particular,
is a linear
combination of a and b.
So there exists
integers-- s and t--
such that s times a,
plus t times b equals 1.
It turns out that it can
also go the other way around,
because if I can write one as
a linear combination of a b,
well I cannot get much
lower than that, right?
So that's really the smallest
possible that I can achieve.
So the GCD must be equal to 1.
So this is a property
that we will be using.
And from this property,
we can already figure out
an interesting property.
So suppose we have a
linear combination that
looks like this.
Then you can imagine
that, sort of,
that s times a is equal
to 1, plus or minus
some linear multiple of b.
So it's sort of-- s times
a is sort of equal to 1,
you can say, up to
a multiple of b.
So you can see a sort
of as an inverse of s.
Because s times a is
equal to one, sort of.
So this is what we're going
to use-- this kind of feeling.
And in order to do that, we
are going to define congruency.
So that's the first
definition for this lecture.
We say x is congruent
to y modulo n,
if-- which we denote as
follows-- x with three bars,
y in between brackets, mod n.
And we say that this is
the case if n divides
the difference between x and y.
So let's have a look
at some examples.
So let's take 31,
and I would like
to show to you that
this is congruent to 16
modulo, between brackets, 5.
Why is this?
Well, I take the difference
between 31 and 16, which is 15,
and I know that 15 is 3 times
5, so 5 divides this difference.
And then by definition,
we can write it like this.
And we say-- that's
the definition--
31 is congruent to 16 modulo 5.
Another example is-- no, we
will stick with this example.
It's pretty clear.
So once we have defined this,
we can continue and talk
about this inverse that
I was talking about.
So we like to, sort of, explain
in this encryption scheme
how we can divide by k.
Actually, we would like to
multiply by an inverse of k.
And we're going to
use this framework.
So we'll have a
new definition that
talks about the
multiplicative inverse.
So it's a new concept.
And you'll give a
couple of examples.
So the multiplicative
inverse of x modulo n
is a number, which we
denote by x and then minus 1
on top of here.
It's a number in the interval 0,
1, all the way up to n minus 1.
Such that x times
x inverse-- so x
times its
multiplicative inverse--
is congruent to 1 modulo n.
So this is the definition
for a multiplicative inverse.
So let's have some examples.
So let's do that over here.
For example, we have that 2
times 3-- which equals 6--
is equal to 1 modulo 5.
Why is this?
Well, 6 minus 1
is divisible by 5,
so I know is congruent
to 1 modulo 5.
So what does this mean?
Well, we can say
that two is actually
equal to the multiplicative
inverse of 3 modulo 5.
We can also say that write 3
is the multiplicative inverse
of 2 modulo 5.
Let's have another example, just
to make it a little bit more
clear.
We know that 5
times 5 equals 25,
and this is
congruent to 1 modulo
6, because 25 is
1 plus 4 times 6.
So now we see something
funny happening,
because 5 is actually equal to
its own multiplicative inverse
modulo 6.
So are there any questions
about these concepts?
Because these are really
basic for the whole lecture,
and this is what you really
need to understand if you do
all the problem sets as well.
Are there any questions?
So now we can
actually start talking
about this second version of the
Turing code that we invented.
Let's have a look
at this remainder.
So let's write it out again.
The remainder of m times
k, after dividing out
as many multiples of p.
Well, we know that this is
congruent to m times k modulo
p.
So why is this?
Well, we just apply the
definition over here.
We take the difference
between those two.
So here we have the
remainder of m times k,
after dividing out as
many multiples of p.
And if you subtract
that from m times k,
well then we have something
that is a multiple of p,
because that's what
we divided out.
So the difference
is a multiple of p,
so that means that p
divides the difference.
And that's the definition of
saying that this remainder is
congruent m k modulo p.
So this is kind of
interesting, because now we
can rewrite over there--
well, not really rewrite,
but we can use this to analyze
the encryption over here.
So m prime is equal
to this remainder.
And we get a
beautifully equation.
We see that the encryption is
congruent to the plain message,
times the key modulo p.
So how do I do decryption?
I can use the multiplicative
inverse of k, right?
So then I can divide k out.
So let's write this out as well.
So suppose I have a
multiplicative inverse--
k to the power minus 1-- that
is congruent to 1 modulo p.
Why do I do this?
Why am I writing this out?
Because you will see
that it is not always
possible to have a
multiplicative inverse.
That's going to be
really a big problem.
And that's where all
these other functions
come in-- the Euler totient
function and Euler's theorem,
and so on.
So it's not really
always the case.
We'll give an
example in a moment.
But suppose that we have a
multiplicative inverse-- modulo
p-- well, then I'm
able to easily compute.
I take m prime, I multiply
it with k inverse.
Well, I'm substituting for
m prime, m times k-- times
k inverse.
I still have this left.
Now I can say that this
is equal to 1 modulo p.
So this is equal, or is
congruent, to m modulo p.
So now we see how we
can do decryption.
We simply use the
multiplicative inverse of k.
And as in the first
Turing code, we
are able to somehow
divide out-- so where
did I have it-- to divide out k.
I did it very differently--
I have a very different
mathematical structure-- but the
idea is, essentially, the same.
I have a multiplicative
inverse of k,
and if I multiply this
with the encryption,
I will get the plain
message, modulo p.
So, am I finished
now is the question.
Well, I know that m is in the
range of 0, 1, all the way up
to p minus 1.
So this means that I
can also rewrite m as--
and I use a similar trick
as what I did over here--
I can rewrite m as they
remainder of m prime times k
inverse, after dividing out as
many copies of p as possible.
So what we did here
is to first prove
that the difference between
those two is a multiple of p.
That's essentially
what congruent modulo p
means-- that's the definition.
So now that I know that the
difference is a multiple of p,
and if I know that m is actually
in this range up to p minus 1,
I can use what we
learned last lecture--
and what the book was talking
about-- that the definition
of the remainder of m prime
times k inverse-- this thing--
after finding out
as many copies of p,
is exactly this plain message m.
OK, so now we the decryption.
So this is decryption.
And that sounds great.
So now, of course, we
are wondering, well,
if we can do this, can we also
attack this scheme, right?
Can we do something bad with it?
Well, it can be used
to break this code,
but in a slightly
more complicated way.
So let's see where I put that.
Right, so what we are
going to use, now-- so when
we talk about
security, and so on,
you can think of
all kinds of ways
to break an encryption scheme.
So we started out with,
in the first version,
well, what if I just
know the encryption?
And then, well, I cannot know
anything about the plain text,
simply because I know that it's
very hard to factor a product
of two large primes.
Then I said, but suppose
I know a little bit more
as an adversary.
Suppose I have a
plain message together
with an encrypted message.
Well, then I could
do this GCD trick
and figure out and
break the scheme.
And now we're going to
do something similar.
And we say, well, suppose that
I do not know two encryptions,
but I know a plain message.
And in corresponding,
encrypted message.
So if I know such a pair,
which is-- I mean, in practice,
such type of information
will be leaked.
Then in this case,
I can break it.
So we call this the known
the plain text attack.
And it assumes that we
know-- as an adversary,
I know a message-- a plain
message, m-- and also
an encryption of this
message, m prime.
And m prime, according
to this scheme,
is the remainder of m times
k, after the dividing out
as many multiples
of p as possible.
Now, we saw-- now,
suppose I know these two.
I'm going to show
you how to break it.
So let's have a look.
The encryption, m prime, is
congruent to m times k modulo
p.
We just proved it over here.
And what do we know?
We know that p is
a public prime.
I know p.
Since it's a prime, I know that
the GCD of m and p equals 1.
So these two are
relatively prime.
So now if they are
relatively prime--
and that's what
we wrote up here--
we know that there exists
this linear combination
of, in this case, m and
p that is equal to 1.
And this way we
can figure out how
to compute the inverse-- the
multiplicative inverse of m.
So that's what
we're going to do.
So we can compute and the
multiplicative inverse, such
that m times m inverse is
congruent to 1 modulo p.
So now we can do the next step.
So what could I do next?
So let's see, if I
have such an inverse,
then I can take my
encrypted message
that I have as an
attacker, which is m prime.
I know m, and
since p was public,
I can compute this
multiplicative inverse.
So I could just
compute this product,
and I know that this is actually
equal to, well, k times m times
m inverse.
This is again equal to--
congruent to 1 modulo p.
So this is equal to k modulo p.
So now, all of a sudden,
I know k modulo p,
because I know those two.
So if I know k, I can compute
its multiplicative inverse.
So I can compute k
inverse modulo p.
And if I know k
inverse, again, I
can use it to decrypt any
other encrypted message
that I receive.
So for all future
encrypted messages,
I do not need anymore
the plain messages.
I've already used-- just
by using one plain message
encryption pair, I have been
able to compute the secret key,
and the whole scheme is broken.
So security is kind of
an interesting science.
We can always think
of more tricks
to break schemes, or
other assumptions,
that we haven't
thought about before.
And so now, let's talk about--
so what did we do here?
We have been talking about
encryption-- these two schemes.
We talked about
modular arithmetic.
congruence, and also
the multiplicative inverse.
And we showed how to use that
to break Turing's code, version
number two.
So we need something
much more fundamental
in order to create a scheme
that is really secure.
And that's what we're
going to do now.
We're going to start off with
Euler's totient function,
and improve a related theorem.
And with that we will be
able to actually explain
RSA algorithm, which is a
famous algorithm invented here
at MIT in 1977, by Rivest,
Shamir, and Adleman.
And they actually also
got the Turing Award
for this a few years ago.
And it's widely
used in practice.
But we will be able
to actually explain
this algorithm with just this
fundamental piece of number
theory.
So that's really exciting.
So let's do this.
So we're going to first define
Euler's totient function.
And it's related to this
multiplicative inverse.
This function is
denoted phi of n,
and it denote the
number of the integers
in 1, 2, 3-- all the way
up to n minus 1, that
are relatively prime to n.
So this just drops out of
the air, you may think.
But this is a
fundamental quantity,
and Euler's theorem is what
we will try to prove next.
But let's give a
couple of examples
about this, just to
see how it works.
So for example, let's
take n to be equal to 12.
What would be the value of
Euler's totient function,
evaluated for 12?
So if you take 12, we have the
following numbers to consider.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10,11, and 12.
So now, let's have a look.
You want to count
the integers that
are relatively prime to 12.
Well, 1 is relatively
prime to 12.
Why is that?
Because to GCD of 12
and 1 is equal to 1,
and that's the definition
of being relatively prime.
So this is a good number.
The GCD of 12 and 2, well
both are divisible by 2.
So they're not relatively
prime, because the GCD
is at least two.
In this case, equal to 2.
3 also divides 12.
4 divides 12.
5 is relatively prime
with respect to 12.
6 actually is
dividing 12 as well.
7 is relatively prime,
and 11 over here as well.
And all the others have
a greatest common divisor
that's larger than 1.
So here we see that the Euler's
totient function evaluated
in 12 is equal to 4.
There are one, two,
three, four integers
that are relatively prime.
OK, so let's have
a different one.
Say, n equals 15.
It's little bit different,
because here you
may think this is kind
of coincidental that 1,
5, 7, and 11 are
actually, also, primes.
But for 15 it looks a
little bit different.
So let's write out
all the numbers.
Again, let's have a look.
Well, one is the
greatest common divisor
equal to 1, with respect to 15.
2 is also relatively
prime, with respect to 15.
3 is dividing 15.
4-- yeah, 4 and 15 have greatest
common divisor equal to 1.
So that's relatively prime.
5 is not.
6 is not.
7 is relatively prime.
8-- again, this is only
divisible by power of 2,
and this has no
power of 2 in it.
9, 10 are-- this one is
divisible by 5, divisible by 3.
11 is, again, relatively prime.
And then we have 13 is
relatively prime as well.
And 14 as well, because
this is 2 times 7,
and this is 3 times 5.
So how many do we see now?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So the Euler's totient
function evaluated in 15
is actually equal to 8.
Now, it turns out
that this function has
really nice properties,
and you can easily
calculate-- if you know
the decomposition of n
into its primes, and
powers of primes--
you can easily compute
this number, phi of n.
Now, you will be able to
find this in the book.
You should read it.
And also, problem
set talks about this.
But for now, let's
just talk about this
is an abstract notion,
because that's all
that we will use
in this lecture.
But you will have
a few exercises
to talk about computing
this kind of stuff.
OK, so let's talk about Euler's
totient function and Euler's
theorem.
So let me use this blackboard.
Now, this is really
an exciting theorem.
And it's a little
bit hard to prove.
So why we'll need a little
bit more time to do this.
Euler's theorem
says the following.
If the GCD of n and
k is equal to 1,
then k to the power [INAUDIBLE]
the Euler's totient function
evaluated in n is actually
congruent to 1 modulo n.
So this is what we're
going to prove here.
So why is this so interesting?
Well, we'll talk about
an application which
is a direct consequence of
this theorem, which we'll
call Fermat's little theorem.
And that, in turn, we will use
to explain the RSA algorithm,
and show how the decryption
works, and so on.
So how can we prove this?
It will start with
a first lemma,
and then we're going to do a few
tricks-- mathematical tricks,
you will see it.
So the first lemma
is that if I know
that the GCD-- which is
what we are assuming,
the statement of the theorum--
if I know that the GCD of n
and k equals 1, then I
know that and a times k--
if a times k is congruent
to b times k modulo n,
then this applies that a
is congruent to b modulo n.
All this seems to be kind
of a straightforward lemma.
I will only talk
about its proof.
So how do we do it?
Well, first of all, I know that
the GCD of n and k equals 1.
So that means that I can create
a multiplicative inverse,
because I know that there's
such a linear combination that
will ends up to 1.
So I have the
multiplicative inverse.
I multiply both sides with
this, and then I will end up to,
a is congruent to b modulo n.
And actually, you can
use some of the facts
on your sheet to prove this.
And in the problem
set, you probably
have seen that there
are a number of problems
related to this.
So you will recognize this,
and prove a few of these things
yourself.
OK, so this is-- so let me see.
So let me see what
we have done here.
Actually, I noticed that
I've missed one statement
that I would like to
explicitly mention.
I mean, I've used
it a few times.
Let me do that first.
Which is that, we know that if
the GCD of n and k equals 1,
then-- this is if, and
only if, the case-- if k
has a multiplicative inverse--
I've not yet explicitly stated
it-- and we can
easily see this--
let me just give a quick
proof to show how this works.
Well, if the GCD is
equal to 1, then we
use the statement up there.
So this is if,
and only if, there
exists a linear combination.
So an s and a t, such that
n times s plus k times t
equals 1.
Well, then I also know that
there exists a t such that,
actually, the difference
between 1 and k times t
is divisible by n.
So n divides the difference
of k times t minus 1.
So why is that?
Well, if I look at the
difference between k times
t and 1, the difference
is n times s.
And n times s is divisible by n.
So now, by the
definition of congruence,
I just apply the
definition over here.
We have written it out here.
We can say that k times t
is congruent to 1 modulo n.
And this is the definition of
the multiplication inverse.
So we have essentially
shown that if the greatest
common divisors in
any case equal to 1,
then it has a
multiplicative inverse.
OK, we have been using
this property over
here because we assume that
the greatest common divisor is
equal to 1.
So we now know that there exists
a multiplicative inverse of k.
We use that one to
multiply away, essentially,
the k out of this
equation, and get
a is congruent to b modulo n.
Also note that we use
the property over here.
We said that we wanted to
compute, what was it again?
Over here-- we started off
with the GCD of m and p
to be equal to 1, and I know p.
And now I can compute the
multiplicative inverse of m.
And I should have
said why it exists.
And it exists
because of that lemma
that I just mentioned up here.
OK, so now let's go
back to Euler's theorem.
This first lemma we are going
to use to prove a second lemma,
and that second
lemma we can finally
use to prove the theorem.
All right, so this lemma I
will put on a separate board,
because it contains quite
a number of steps to prove.
So the lemma states that, if we
suppose that the GCD of n and k
equals 1-- so it's the same
assumptions as before-- if it
lets k1 all the way up to k r to
be those integers in the range
1, 2, 3, and so
on, to n minus 1,
that are relatively
prime-- so these denote
the integers relatively
prime to n-- then
we can prove a very
interesting property.
Now, notice by the
way, that r in here
is equal to this value of
the Euler's totient function
evaluated in n.
Because this counts
the total number
of numbers that are relatively
prime with respect to n.
So now we can prove
something really spectacular.
We can show that the
set that contains
all of these remainders--
the remainder of k 1 times k,
after dividing out this
many multiples of n
as possible, all the way to
the remainder off k r times k,
after dividing out as many
multiples of n as possible,
this set is actually equal
to the set k 1 up to k r.
So this is what
we're going to prove.
And we'll do it in two steps.
We first show that this
set has exactly r numbers.
So the cardinality of
that set is equal to r.
So that will be our
first step in the proof.
And over here we will show that
every remainder is actually
relatively prime to n, so
it must be part of this set.
So we will show that this
is a subset of this set
in a second part of the proof.
And combining those two, we
are able to prove equality.
Why's that?
Well I have r distinct
elements in this set,
I have r distinct elements
in this set, this one
is a subset of this.
So that can only happen
if they are equal.
So this is the
method for the proof.
I should-- so we'll start
with the first part.
And the way to do that is to
see whether it is possible
that any two remainders
in that set, can they
be equal to one another?
We will show that
that's not possible.
So if it's not possible,
then all these remainders
must be different.
And we have exactly r of those.
So let's do this.
So the proof for
1 is as follows.
Let's assume that we
he have to remainders.
Say, k i times k, and a
remainder k j times k,
after dividing out as
many multiples of n.
And supposed that they
are equal to one another.
We're going to show
that this can only
happen if k i is equal to k j.
And if you can see
that, well then
we know that all these different
remainders are actually
different from one another.
And if they're all
different from one another,
then we must have exactly r.
Because we have k 1
up to k r in here.
OK let's see where
we can do this.
Well, if you know that
these two remainders are
equal to one another, we can
look at them with respect
to these definitions over here.
And we can show that k
i times k is actually
congruent to k j
times k modulo n.
So why is this?
Well, these two
remainders are the same.
And k i times k is
equal to this remainder,
plus a multiple of n.
This k j times k is equal
to this remainder plus,
a multiple of n.
So the difference between those
two is also a multiple of n.
And that's the
definition of congruence.
So now we can use
our first lemma,
which is stated over here.
We know that we assumed
in Euler's theorem
that the GCD of n
and k is equal to 1.
If a times k is congruent
to b times k modulo n,
then we know that's a is
congruent to b modulo n.
So let's apply it over
here, and take for a k
i, and for b we can take k j.
So now we see that key k i
is congruent to k j modulo n.
And from this we will
conclude-- and that
takes an extra step-- that k
i is actually equal to k j.
So how can we do this?
Well, we know that k i and k
j are both in the range from 1
all the way up to n minus 1.
So if I look at the
difference between those
two-- so by definition
of congruence
I know that n divides
k i minus k j.
I know that this one is in the
range from 0 up to n minus 1.
This one is in the range
of 0 up to n minus 1.
The only way how a difference
of two numbers in this range
can be divisible by n, is if
this thing is equal to zero.
And that means that
k i equals k j.
So now we are done
with the first part,
because we have shown
that if I take any two
remainders over here it
must be that they can only
be equal to one another
if, actually, the k i is
equal to the k j.
So actually we're looking
at the same remainder.
So they remainders in this
set are all different,
and there are
exactly r of those.
So now we go to the
second part of the proof.
And notice that we
are-- so far we've only
been proving the second
lemma, and we still
need to go to Euler's
theorem as well.
So it still takes a few steps.
So how do we do the second part?
Well, we saw in last
lecture that we were
explaining Euclid's algorithm.
And we used, essentially,
this property.
We said that the greatest
common divisor between n
and the remainder of
say, k i times k and n,
is actually equal to the
greatest common divisor of n
and k i times k.
So why is this, again?
Well, the remaining is
actually equal to k i times k,
minus a multiple of n, right?
So the greatest common
divisor is therefore--
between n and this-- is the same
as the greatest common divisor
between n and k i times k.
So you should have to
look at last lecture.
And now we are pretty much done.
Why is this?
Because we have assumed that
the greatest common divisor
between n and k is equal to 1.
And k i, in the
statement of the lemma,
is relatively prime to n.
And that means, according to
the definition over there,
that the greatest common
divisor between k i and n
is also equal to 1.
So we know that both
these greatest common
divisors are equal to 1.
So that means that there is
no common divisor between n
and these, except 1 of course.
So what does this say?
Well, this means that
this remainder, according
to our definition, is
relatively prime to n,
because this greatest common
divisor is equal to 1.
So if it is an integer
relatively prime to n,
then it must be one
of those k i's, k j's
in this set that is
stated in the lemma.
So this shows that it must be
part of this set over here.
So if proven, the fact
[? is ?] that the set of all
the remainders is a subset
of the set k 1 of the k r.
So now we're done.
So now that we have shown
this particular lemma,
we can continue and
prove Euler's theorem.
And I'll probably need
to wipe out some of this.
So let's use this lemma
to prove this theorem.
So this is really a neat trick.
So the proof of Euler's
theorem is as follows.
We're going to take the product
of all those k i's over there,
and see where we can
find a nice relationship.
So we take k 1 times k
2, all the way times k r.
And we know, because those two
sets are actually the same,
that this is equal
to the remainder--
the first remainder--
k 1 times k,
after dividing out as
many multiples of n.
And we go all the way
up to the final one,
the remainder of k r
times k, dividing out
as many multiples of n.
So now we can see that--
well, we've already
shown that each of
those remainders
is congruent to, in
this case, this one
is congruent to k
1 times k modulo n.
And this one is congruent
to k r times k modulo n.
So let's write it out.
So it's k 1 times k.
And then we have k 2 times k.
And finally we have
k r times k modulo n.
So let's regroup those.
We see k 1, k 2, all the
way up to k r reappearing.
And we have a k here,
a k here, and we
have that r times--
so we have times
k to the power r modulo n.
So now we are able to, again,
use this particular lemma
over here.
So what do we do?
Well, we know that k 1
is relatively prime to n.
And k 2 is as well,
all the way up to k r.
So this whole product is also
relatively prime, with respect
to n.
That means that the
greatest common divisor
of this whole product
with n is equal to 1.
So that means that I can
divide out this whole product.
We have-- so let's do this.
We have 1 times this product.
We take this for a,
and we take this for b.
And then we can divide
this whole thing out
according to this
particular lemma,
by using the multiplicative
inverse of that product.
So now we see that the 1 is
equal to k to the power r
modulo n.
And remember, in our
theorem, r over here
in this lemma-- r is
actually equal to the Euler's
totient function in n.
So now this equation
proves the whole theorem.
OK, so now I'm going
to talk about RSA,
which is the last part here.
So maybe you all
would like to have
a little break of a couple of
minutes, just to relax a bit.
And then-- and shake
hands with your neighbors,
and jump up in the
air if you'd like to.
All right let's start
with the RSA algorithm.
So we have done everything
up to this point.
And we are actually-- we have
done these two over here.
We still have to talk about
Fermat's little theorem.
But then we can go for RSA,
and it uses this consequence
of Euler's theorem.
So Fermat's little
theorem is actually
talking about what happens
if n is a prime number.
It says, well,
suppose p is a prime.
And if you have k in the
range 1, 2, all the way up
to p minus 1, then we
can conclude that k
to the power of p minus 1
is congruent to 1 modulo n.
And we can directly prove
this by using Euler's theorem.
So how do we do this?
Well, we know that p is prime.
So the numbers 1, 2, all
the way up to p minus 1,
are actually
relatively prime to p.
So why is that?
Well, p is prime.
So the greatest common divisor
between any of those with p
is equal to 1.
That's the definition
of relatively prime.
And we know that
we can now apply
Euler's theorem
over here, and see
that k to the power phi of
p is, of course, congruent
to 1 modulo p.
That's Euler's theorem.
But now, since we know that
these are the exact ones that
are relatively prime,
we can explicitly
compute the Euler's
totient function of p.
Because there are p
minus 1 numbers that
are relatively prime to p.
So that's the
definition over here.
So the number of integers in
the range 1 up to p minus 1--
they're all relatively prime.
So we know that 5 p
is equal to p minus 1.
So now we have shown that
k to the power of p minus 1
is congruent to 1 modulo k.
This is kind of interesting
because we can use this theorem
also to compute the
multiplicative inverse of k,
in this particular case.
So how do we do this?
We just take k,
and we look at what
happens if you multiply k with
k to the power of p minus 2.
Well, this is equal to k to
the power p minus 1, which
is congruent to 1 modulo p
according to Fermat's theorem.
So now, when we look
at the definition
of multiplicative
inverse over here,
we see that k to
the power p minus 2
is actually the
multiplicative inverse of k.
So k inverse is actually
equal to k to the power
p minus 2 modulo k.
All right, so this theorem
we're going to use now
in the description of RSA.
As I said, it was only
decades later, after Turing,
Rivest, Shamir, and Adleman
were the first to really show
how number theory
could be applied so
successfully in cryptography.
And they essentially showed
the first public key encryption
scheme in which a sender and
receiver do not necessarily
have to exchange a secret key.
That's not necessary.
So they had a public key method.
And that's still used today,
and it's a great inventions.
So how does the RSA work?
Again, we have to talk
with an encryption scheme
about what happens beforehand.
So beforehand, we need to
generate this public key
and a secret key.
So the idea is that the receiver
creates a public key, and also
a secret key.
He will publish the public
key, and he will keep
the secret key for himself.
And now anybody can
use the public key
to encrypt a message.
The encrypted message
is sent to the receiver,
and he's going to use his
secret key to get back
to the plain message.
So how is he going to do this?
Well in the first
step, the idea is
to generate two distinct primes.
Turns out that this can be
done in a very efficient way.
There are lots of primes
among the integers.
So you just sample.
And it turns out that
you can test primality
with a pretty high
probability, very efficiently.
And recently,
actually, there has
been a deterministic
algorithm that is polynomial.
And a number of
bits of the primes
that can actually tell you
whether you have a prime
or not.
So you can do this.
Two, we're going to create
the product of these two
distinct primes.
And that's where our
assumption is going to help us.
That it is hard to factor a
product of two large primes.
That's going to be the
underlying hardness assumption
of the RSA encryption scheme.
So let n be this.
Three, we are going to
select an integer e,
such that the greatest
common divisor of e
with the product p
minus 1 times q minus 1
is actually equal to 1.
And the public-- and once
we have created this,
the public key is going
to be a pair that consists
of e itself together with n.
So that's the public key.
And the secret key is going
to be computed as follows,
in step four.
We are going to compute.
d, such that d times e
is congruent to 1 modulo
that product of p minus
1 times q minus 1.
Can we do this?
Yeah, because the greatest
common divisor between e
and that product is equal to 1.
And we have shown over
here that, therefore, it
has a multiplicative inverse.
And first of all, we know
that the solution d exists,
and we can also
efficiently compute it.
So the secret key is
going to be the pair that
consists of d and also n.
So how does it work?
The sender knows the
public key, e and n,
and uses those to
encrypt a message.
I will explain it in a moment.
And then the receiver knows
the secret key, d and n,
and then is able to decrypt.
OK, so let's see how
encryption works.
And then we will have to
do a lot of mathematics
to get the decryption going.
So m prime, which is computed--
so the encrypted plain text is
computed as the remainder
of m to the power e--
which is part of
the public key--
and then dividing out as many
multiples of n as possible.
It turns out-- and we are going
to prove this-- that decryption
works as follows.
We can compute m
by using m prime.
So we receive m prime.
What do we do?
We're going to take m prime,
raise it to the power d-- which
is part of the secret
key-- and then dividing out
as many multiples of n.
Now, why would that work?
Why would this work?
So let's prove this
step over here.
Well, it turns out that they
can apply Fermat's theorem,
and the idea is as follows.
So let's have a look.
We know that m prime is equal
to the remainder of m raised
to the power e, which
is congruent to m
to the power e, modulo n.
We've seen this now a
number of times, right?
So what does this imply?
This implies that m prime to
the power d is actually equal--
is congruent to m to the
power e, to the power d.
So I just raised this
side to the power d,
and I raised this
side to the power d.
And I still-- and
I know, now, that m
prime to the power d is
equal to m to the power e d--
congruent to m to the
power e d modulo n.
So now we know that there
exists an integer r.
We are going to use the
fact that we have that e
and p minus 1 times q
minus 1 as a greatest
common divisor over 1.
So we know that e times
d is actually equal to 1,
plus r times p minus
1, times q minus 1.
Actually, what I use here is
the fact-- is this over here.
By definition of
congruency, I know
that the difference
between those two-- d times
e and 1-- is divisible
by this product.
So I know that there
exists an integer such
that e times d equals 1, plus
a multiple of that product.
That's how it works.
So we know that m
prime to the power
d-- we already saw that it is
equal to m to the power e d,
which is congruent
to-- well, we just
replace e d by 1 plus
r times this multiple.
So we have m to the
power 1, times m
to the power-- this part--
r p minus 1, q minus 1.
So now we're finally going
get to Fermat's theorem.
We know that n is the
products of p and q,
and I'm not actually
sure I do this here.
So let's apply Fermat's theorem
and see how we can use this.
So if m is not
congruent to 0 modulo p,
well then we can apply
Fermat's theorem.
Where is it?
It's over here.
We can only apply this if
k is in the range from 1
to p minus 1 is
not equal to zero.
So if m is not equal to 0--
not congruent to 0 modulo p--
then we can apply
the theorem and state
that m to the power p minus
1 is congruent to 1 modulo p.
And in the same way,
we can do this for q.
So if this is not
true-- modulo q-- then m
to the power q minus 1 is
congruent to 1 modulo q.
So here we have used
Fermat's theorem twice.
Now we can apply what
we have learned before,
which is what we
wrote down over here.
And prime to the power d is
congruent to this modulo n.
Now n is p times q, so let's
have a look at what that means.
It means that since n
is a product of p and q,
we can also look at
this congruent modulo p.
So in particular, we know
that m prime to the power
d is congruent to m times
m r p minus 1 times q minus
1 modulo p.
Why is that?
Well, we know that n
divides this difference
by the definition of congruency.
n is equal to p times q.
So if n is dividing
this difference,
also p is dividing
this difference.
So that's why we can write
it m prime to the power d
is congruent to this
thing, modulo p.
And of course, we can
repeat this for q.
So let me write
this out as well.
So there it is.
So now we can there use what
we have figured out over here.
So we know that if
m is not equal to 0,
then this thing over
here cancels out.
Because m to the power p
minus 1 is congruent to 1.
So we have that m
prime to the power
d is congruent to m
modulo p, if m is not
congruent to 0 modulo p, right?
Because if m is not
congruent to zero,
we have this
particular equation.
We plug it in over
here, this all cancels,
and we just are left with m.
Now, if m is equal-- is
congruent-- to 0 modulo p,
then we can see that
it is equal to 0.
So it's equal to 0.
So this actually
holds for any case.
Now we can do the same for
q-- the same argument--
and show that this must hold.
So now we know that p
divides the difference
of m prime d minus m.
q is another prime that
divides this difference.
And the only way that's possible
is if the product of p and q
is dividing this particular
number-- this difference.
And we have two different
primes dividing the same number,
so the product
must [? divided. ?]
So p times q divides
m prime d minus m.
Oh, but p times q is equal to n.
So now we're almost
done, because now we
can state-- by the
definition of congruency--
that m prime to the power d
is congruent to m modulo n.
Now, since m is a message that's
in the range of-- so I did not
write it down here--
so m is a message
which is in the range of 0
all the way up to n minus 1.
We know, and we have seen it
before with Turing's code,
that we can rewrite this
and say that m equals
the remainder of m
prime to the power
d, after multiplying out as
many multiples of n as possible.
So here you go.
So this is the decryption
rule, and it works.
We have shown that this
equation truly holds.
So RSA has really
withstood the test of time.
It's already out there
for many decades,
and it's still widely used.
I wanted to talk a
little bit about this,
but there seemed not
to be enough time.
But I'd just like to mention
that only 2009 Craig Gentry
proved a beautiful theorem,
and was able to evaluate
Boolean circuits.
Or, say, certain types of
programs under encryption.
So you can sort of add
and multiply cypher text
encryptions together, and it
is as if you multiply them
at the plain text level.
That was a fantastic-- that
was an enormous open problem.
And he solved it.
And only a few months
earlier, in 2010,
in joint work with Craig and
some other colleagues at IBM,
we showed it with
very simple arithmetic
that just uses modulo p and
modulo 2 kind of things.
We could show a
construction this
has such a property--
such an encryption
scheme of the integers.
So there's still a lot of
stuff going on in this area.
And really, we use this
type of very basic stuff.
The problem in cryptography
is to show that it is secure.
So you have to show
that breaking the scheme
needs to be reduced to
some really hard problem.
And that is always the
really difficult part
of such type of research.
OK, well, have lots of
fun with recitation.